Hello大家好
歡迎來到
周慕資放心說
我是周慕資心理師
好 最近啊有時候
會看到大家
在我們的評論留言
有些朋友會説
慕資老師你們的頻道
聲音特別小聲
我聽你們有時候會
不是很清楚
那我想問問大家
是不是真的有這個狀況呢？
如果有的話可以在
YT留言讓我知道
因為我們有特別
留意這個狀況 然後
做一些調整
那也有可能是因為有時候
我在講到一些比較身心的
東西的時候
我聲音可能會放小
所以會讓大家覺得
好像聲音有點變小
所以這個部分呢
我們會稍微留意 好的
那今天要跟大家分享的
是十分鐘心理學 這個
十分鐘心理學
主題是跟整理和收納有關
那就是為什麼收納跟清潔
是一個心理療癒
從囤積症開始跟大家討論
那講到
收納跟清潔 我不知道
大家喜不喜歡整理東西
我自己其實
不是一個很喜歡
整理東西的人
這時候就是要拿MBTI
出來做藉口的話因為
我是 P 人 所以
我很不喜歡整理東西 但
其實沒有關係
我就是一個不喜歡
整理東西的人
可是我知道
有很多人喜歡整理東西
特別是如果覺得有
要遇到很困難的任務
或是遇到有些事情
覺得很煩的時候
他反而會開始整理東西
為什麼呢？
因為感覺會把東西
一個一個放在自己
想像的順序裡面
好像自己生命還有
自己的思考
也慢慢的就是
開始有秩序了起來
可以讓自己的思緒
變得比較清楚
因此收納跟清潔
它是不是可以幫助
我們的人生呢？
我覺得它的確
是一個心理的療慾
這也就是為什麼
之前有個所謂的日本的收納達人
出了很多書告訴我們
斷捨離其實對
我們的人生非常非常的重要
我們的空間長什麼樣子
的確也會
跟我們的心理是什麼
狀況有關
而有些人會認為
如果你在你的空間裡面
放了太多 就是
沒有需要的東西
可能也代表你的
心裡其實被很多
沒有需要的東西佔得滿滿的
因此今天要來跟
大家聊聊關於收納
跟清潔對我們心理
療癒的功能以及囤積症
它可能發生的
理由跟對我們的影響喔！
首先先聊聊心理
層面的清潔療癒
對我們來說
你看當你開始在慢慢的
去做一些擦拭
把一個地方從
很亂變得很整齊的那
一個過程 會不會
感覺有點成就感呢？
即使是像我這麼不
喜歡整理東西的人
有的時候呢
我其實是很喜歡刷洗
就是浴室裡面的
一些浴缸啊 或者
是那個洗臉盆 哪怕
它從稍微有點黃的然後刷洗
到很潔白的那個感覺 會讓
我很有成就感
為什麼呢？
因為這件事情會讓
我們建立起內在的秩序
跟掌控感
也就是回覆你的控制感
你做了它就會變乾淨
這種東西就是一種行動層面的
自我效能
而當我們今天有一些就是生活中
沒有辦法掌控
覺得煩悶的事情的時候
我們在做這件事情
會讓我們覺得
我們好像有
一些掌控感 好像
做得到一些什麼
也會讓我們對
自己多一點點信心
這個其實會帶給
我們一個很大的正向感受
所以有很多人就說
他在寫論文的時候
家裡都特別乾淨
因為他都不寫
論文 都在整理 家裡然後
有些人就會笑
而實際上有的時候
我們在做這件事情的
時候 做整理東西
這件事情的時候
我們頭腦可能也在懂嗎 因為
我們在做整理的時候
我們的注意力是
在我們整理的這個東西上
但是呢 我們頭腦
可能一方面也
在消化 也許我
剛剛讀的書 或是這
一個讓我卡到的問題
因此呢 在這個過程中
我們的心跟我們的頭腦
它可能看起來
是在做清潔工作 但
我們的心可能處在一個心流
狀態 它讓
我們可以脫離那
一個讓我焦慮的事情
可是大腦有可能還是
可以自己運作
而當我們自己在做這個
就是清潔的事情的時候
某方面是一種動態
冥想的感覺 這
可以帶給我們一些平靜
跟安全感
那另外我剛剛有提到
關於囤積症
可能有很多人發現 就是特別
是像有一些可能自己
一個人生活
或是年紀很大的
一些阿公阿嬤
或者是爸爸媽媽
他們好像會有
囤積症的狀況 那
就是把東西
堆的 甚至整個房子都是
不需要的東西
囤積症它的確
是一種心理疾患 患者會
非常難以丟棄物品
即使這些東西不具功能價值
是為什麼 會讓
自己處在這樣的狀況呢？
之前我很常在
我的 Pocast 聊到的
一部電影 叫做令人討厭的
松子的一生 裡面的宗旨
在一開始的時候 其實他
後來有一個理髮師的工作的時候
他的家裡是
很乾淨的
但是這個乾淨的家裡 當
他回到家講
我回來了！的時候
也就是我回來的時候
家裡是很空曠的 只有回憶
什麼都沒有 那
是一個很恐怖的
感覺 就是
我好寂寞
我的旁邊什麼東西
都沒有 什麼人都沒有
那是一個非常空曠的感受
而那個空曠會帶來
很深的孤單感
於是在後來
就是他整個生活崩潰 他發現
他怎麼努力都沒有
辦法得到他要的東西
他原本賴以為生覺得他
只要靠努力就可以得到
他想要的關係 讓
自己的生活慢慢回到軌道
可是後來他發現
他不管再怎麼努力
這個生活永遠不會
如他所願的時候
他崩潰了 而
他崩潰的方式就是他的家裡
變成了一個囤積症
患者的房子 那
就是整個房子堆滿了東西
你再看他把整個房子堆滿
東西的時候 雖然會覺得
好像很亂、很不舒服
可是你有沒有感覺到 當他
一踏入這個家的時候
那個空虛感跟空曠感
不見了 因為整個
家都是東西
這都是囤積症患者常常
就是出現了
一個狀況 那
就是他需要囤積
這麼多東西跟
他內在的狀況有關
例如說他有發生一些事情 讓
他覺得失去掌控感 讓
他覺得非常的無力
非常的害怕
於是他需要去獲得
掌控感 買
東西讓自己
可以擁有那個東西
而那個東西就放在家裡
我想要的時候隨時都有 這
就是一個最簡單的掌控感
而這也會從我們例如說一些年紀
比較大的父母
或是阿公阿嬤身上看到
有些人會說什麼家裡的
冰箱啊 櫥櫃啊 有
很多已經過期的東西
阿公阿嬤還是不捨得丟
或是爸爸媽媽不捨得丟
就說之後還會用到
之後還可以吃什麼的這個人
他們曾經就是經歷過
很窮困甚至沒有
東西吃的生活
以至於對於
就是食物這件事情有
很嚴重的匱乏
感有關 因此囤積症
幾乎都跟匱乏感有關
而當我們今天為了
要讓自己感受
到安全感 囤積了
這麼多東西 但
實際上那些東西都
不是我們想要的時候
我們的生命
跟生活要怎麼樣可以成為
我們想要的樣子呢？
其實那是不容易的
有時候我們只是帶著
這樣的安全感
希望能夠活著而已
所以如果在這個時候 你
開始也希望讓
自己的生活有
一些不一樣
或者讓我們自己能夠有
一些選擇
開始學著去選擇你的生命
中想要出現哪些東西
把不需要的東西
清除你的生命裡面
或是將你的空間清楚一些
只有留下你喜歡的
東西的這個方式
我想是一個非常重要
也具有聊療癒意義的
一個方法
當我們開始 就是練習
把我們的空間
還有我們生存的地方
開始清空自己
不需要的東西 留下自己
想要的東西 這對
我們來說也是
一個非常重要的
宣佈是什麼呢？
也就代表著我們以前認為要
藉由留下這個東西 來
獲得安全感
我會知道我不再需要留下那些
我不那麼喜歡但
可以帶給我安全感的東西
因為現在的
我已經可以給自己安全感了
所以我開始可以有選擇
我開始可以選擇
我想要的東西
我開始選擇我的生命
可以藉由我想要的東西 來
得到安全感
而不是我擁有
什麼東西 來得到安全感
那有些時候 我們從另外
一個角度看 有些人會
覺得他在越焦慮的時候越
覺得不想打掃 甚至
原因是因為 當
我們情緒太多、壓力
太大的時候
我們大腦其實會
處在一個暫時
關閉的狀態 它會讓
我們一直專注在
自己焦慮的事情
而外在的所有的
變化 包含聲音也好
一些狀態也好 對於
他全部都是干擾 因為對
他來說他 只想注意力
放在這一個會讓他
焦慮的事情上
有些人會說
為什麼我們要放在讓
我們焦慮的事情
上 原因是因為
如果焦慮本身
是一個提醒 它會讓
我以為我只有解決
掉這個焦慮 我才可以放鬆
但實際上外界的
一些聲音 外界的
一些香味
一些狀況
可能都會幫助
我們放鬆 但是那個時候
我們的大腦
卻沒有辦法接收這個部分
因此如果有的時候
你開始覺得很心煩意亂
我也覺得想打掃 但是
我覺得
我好像動不起來
這個時候選一個會讓
你覺得很舒服
療癒的聲音
可能會幫助
你慢慢地讓你的身體回到這
一個做你想做的事情的
節奏 所以
你可以選一些會讓你聽了覺得
可以慢慢沉靜下來
而且覺得瞭解的聲音
例如說 有些人會
喜歡鳥叫聲、
雨聲、瀑布聲、頌缽聲
或者是一些你覺得很熟悉的
一些吸塵器的運轉聲等等
讓聲音可以幫助你重新調整
你的身體和心理的節奏
當你的身體
跟上了 心理也會跟上
那接下來我想要跟大家
就是分享一個轉化
練習 就是希望
可以讓整理成為心理的療癒儀式
好的
可能有些人就會說老師
你自己好像
也不是很喜歡整理 那
你這樣子要教
我們做這個心理治療儀式
我可能不是
一個很喜歡整理書籍讓東西
很整齊的人
但是我個人其實很喜歡
刷洗東西
就是因為我
是一個會去洗碗然後把洗手槽
刷得乾乾淨淨的人
這也是我的
一種療癒儀式
真的蠻鼓勵大家的當
你開始覺得你的身心
狀態不是那麼的穩定 而
你發現你的
生活環境的確也會讓
你開始覺得煩躁 而
你 沒有任何一點空間
可以讓你慢慢地休息
跟療癒的時候
我會蠻鼓勵
大家從小區域
開始 慢慢地讓
自己用自己的步調
去整理自己的生活
也可以整理自己的心
每天一個抽屜 一個角落
你會從那一點點的
整理中感覺到自己的
一點點改變
就很像是我那個年紀的
時候 我們的小學課本叫
一束鮮花的故事 就是買了
一束鮮花 回到家把它插瓶
之後突然覺得我的生活
有這束花 好像很棒
那麼我需要做些什麼 讓
我周圍的環境
可以配得上這一束花呢？
可以變成我想要的樣子呢？
就是用這樣的方式
一點一點的去調整
你想要的生活
而在整理的時候
我會很鼓勵大家
可以搭配情緒的辨識 那
就是這個東西代表什麼？
我為什麼留著它
它留著的意義是什麼？
我真的需要它嗎？
還是我只是很習慣
覺得這個東西留著
我 比較有安全感？
因此每天給
自己五分鐘的時間
去做一些整理跟清潔的工作
可以讓空間重新
呼吸 也會讓你
自己慢慢的安靜下來
不只是外界的聲音
也包括自己的呼吸聲 讓
空氣裡的混亂
一點一點的沉澱
真正的療癒是讓
你能在不完美的
環境裡 仍感覺到
自己是安全可呼吸的 所以留
一點空白 一點聲音
一點生活的痕跡
你可以將空間變成
你想要的樣子 但不需要對
自己太過嚴格
因為那一點生活的痕跡
就是你活著的證明
安靜的房間
乾淨的空間 除了
整潔 更是我值得被
好好對待的證明
當我們願意為了
自己擦桌子、折
衣服、吸地掃地
我們其實也在告訴自己
我值得一個乾淨
舒服的生活 而
我希望能夠幫助大家
理解　整理不是一個
我們一定要做的事 但
它卻是一個
我們自我照顧的
一個非常重要的表達
所以最後提醒
大家 真正的整理不僅僅
是丟掉東西
而是學會留下
真正重要的自己
既然今天提到把外
在整理好 內在也會
比較安定的概念 這裡
也順便分享
一個把清潔流程變
簡單的工具 也
就是工商服務時間
那就是LG CordZero A9X
蒸汽濕拖無限吸塵器
我自己很喜歡這個吸塵器
自動集塵的功能
會把吸塵器集塵盒的垃圾
直接清掉
不用自己手動清理
非常方便
以前自己手動清理
超容易打噴嚏
一不小心還會
把灰塵毛髮都
掉落在地上 等於白掃
但現在只要聽著那個
自動集塵的聲音
就會有一種
今天的結束被好好的收起來
的感覺
像是你在對自己說
好了
可以放鬆了 對我來說
這不只是打掃
更像是一種聲音療癒的儀式
再來分享一下外觀跟手感
直立式的極簡機身
加上智慧集塵收納充電座
拿起來
又只有 2.47 公斤
大約兩瓶牛奶的重量
非常好移動 但機器又是280瓦的
強勁吸力
我比較常用的LED
輕薄地板吸頭
做的蠻薄的 而且前緣有燈
床底 燈暗處
看得到也吸得到
接下來想跟大家
介紹三個重點
讓日常清潔更有效率
一、自動集塵
吸完放回基座 它會
自動把集塵盒的灰塵
吸到集塵袋
接著會啟動集塵座內的 UVC
紫外線殺菌 防止細菌
以及異味產生
不用自己倒不會飛灰
直接省下時間跟麻煩
二、換上蒸汽雙旋濕拖吸頭 高溫的旋轉
拖布等於有人幫你手擦
所以日常就是吸加拖
一次完成非常方便
三、深入清潔
高速震動除塵蟎 這個
家裡有過敏的人
非常非常適合這個功能像有
一些寢具布沙發
可以改接高速震動除蟎吸頭
每分鐘4000次拍打
把參層塵蟎和粉塵
帶起來 再吸走
深層乾淨 不傷布料
所有的吸頭都可以收納在
智慧集塵收納充電座
讓你每日的五分鐘清潔
可以輕鬆隨手拿工具
當我們從事重複
而節奏穩定的家務行為
像吸地
擦拭東西 摺衣服等等
因為結果可預期
所以大腦會分泌
多巴胺跟血清素
讓我們的情緒逐漸穩定
焦慮感下降
每天回家花五分鐘做小清潔
就能讓空間重新呼吸
也讓你的腦袋有機會重開機
如果你也想把清潔變成
好執行的步驟
LG A9X 蒸汽濕拖無線吸塵器
能幫你把流程做得直覺
也更容易在忙錄裡
維持一個能呼吸的空間
歡迎大家需要清潔工具時
可以參考看看喔！
今天跟大家分享了清潔
跟整理與心理療癒的關係
希望大家會喜歡
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見了拜拜